so she is a good friend of yours or you
are developing a friendship with her I
would say you know what I think a friend
is someone because I've had friends that
haven't been there for me that have
known me for a long time and we've hung
out and we've done those things but in
the times of need in where the hell are
they and so I would say she's a good
friend and it doesn't it's not about how
many hours spent or how many inside
jokes you have but it's about the real
[ __ ] and I anytime I've Ever Needed her
to help me with something I'm doing and
then also just it's got to be confusing
I'd like to be a real friend for her
that isn't a friend that people I feel
like people have these friendships that
are really based on hey you know you're
famous I'm famous and we come together
we're like so famous and it's really
stupid and it's not really a real
friendship and you probably talk you
know where everyone can see it more than
you talk privately and her and I you
know we kind of text her if I ever see
anything and I never even know if it's
true or not because people say crazy
[ __ ] about me all the time but I'll just
text her and say you know I'm really
thinking about you if you ever want to
talk to me she's kind of one of my
favorite artists right now because the
thing that I really like about her is
her I have worked together a little bit
before we did Don't Dream It's Over and
the thing that I've really loved about
her is anything I've ever asked her to
be involved in whether it's with happy
hippie or working with you know young
homeless kids or whatever she's always
done right there so I can never say a
bad thing about her because she's always
been so great so in other words she
doesn't have she doesn't have to consult
27 people if you call her and ask her
and I got to do one love Manchester with
her which I thought was just one of the
most it was great yeah amazing moments
ever with these kind of devastating
things that that just is something that
I can't even believe happened and that
she was able to so quickly put together
an event that when you were there even
more than getting to see it from you
know what they've released but standing
on the stage and seeing like you could
almost see this little kind of like Ray
of like hope over everybody and it you
know when you when there's positivity is
light people shine light it literally
there was like this kind of glow of
everyone of this like hope
foreign